نبدا من تطورات لازمه الاوكرانيه حيث قصف
الجيش الروسي واوكرانيا باكثر من 120
صاروخا ودوت صافرات الانذار في العاصمه
كياب وعده مدن اوكرانيه اخرى فيما جرى
تفعيل الانذار الجوي داخل مقاطعه روسيه
على بعد 500 كم من اوكرانيا وفي التفاصيل
اسقطت الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه جسما
مجهولا بالقرب
على بعد 500 كلم من الحدود الاوكرانيا
وذلك بعد ثلاثه ايام من هجوم بطائره مسيره
استهدفت قاعده جويه في المنطقه واشار حاكم
الى ان التهديد على سلامه السكان انتهى
بعد الحادثه
من جهتي اكد الجيش الاوكراني تعرض مناطق
عده في البلاد لضربات صاروخيه روسيه واسعه
نطاق شملت العاصمه كييف بصواريخ كروز تطلق
من طائرات وسفن وافاد مسؤولون محليون في
خير
عن تعرض مدنهم لضربات صاروخيه روسيه عنيفه
وتسجيل عده انفجارات مع محاولات الدفاعات
الجويه للتصدي للصواريخ كما اشارت
التقارير الى ان الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه اسقطت خمسه صواريخ روسيه فوق
ميكو لايف والصاروخ اخر في سوني وذكرت
مصادر ان الموجه الجديده للضربات الروسيه
تسببت في اصابه ثلاثه اشخاص
وقطع التيار الكهربائي فيها بنسبه 40%
بنسبه 90% وقال القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه الثانيه
64 صاروخا صباحا اليوم
خطب ردت سيوه استراليا
مشيرا الى ان تطوير سلاح البحريه سيضمن
امن روسيا لسنوات قادمه وشاهد بوتين عبر
الفيديو رفع العلم الروسيه على الطراد
النووي سوف وسفينه الصواريخ الصغيره
من موسكو تنضمي ليلى
حذيفه عادل اهلا بكم ابدا معك حذيفه كان
هناك من تطورات جديده في المشهد بعد
الاستهداف الكبير
ايضا مدن اخرى اوكرانيا اليوم
سقط صاروخ روسي في هذا المنزل او ما تبقى
من المنزل او الذي كان منزلا هنا الذي دمر
هنا بشكل كامل كما تشاهد في الصوره امامك
عمال النظافه الان يعملون على نظافه
الطريق امام هذه المنازل التي دمرت بشكل
كبير جرى هذا القص هذا هو المنزل الذي كان
يعيش فيه اربعه اشخاص طبعا لسخريه القدر
خالتها هؤلاء الاشخاص هم من النازحين من
مدينه ماريوبل الذين لجاوا الى كيف اظن
منهم طبعا الوضع سيكون امن ولكن طبعا لحقت
به من الصواريخ الروسيه حتى هنا حتى الان
لا احد يعلم من الجيران اذا كانوا كانوا
موجودين في المنزل العامله عمال الانقاذ
والدفاع
في رفع الانقاض والبحث عن ضحايا لم يجدوا
في هذا المنزل الان اي ضحيه وهذا المنزل
الذي امامك الان في الشاشه هذا هو المنزل
الذي اصيب فيه ثلاثه اشخاص الجد والابنه
والحفيده ونقلوا الى المستشفى لتلقي
الرعايه الصحيه كما تتابع امامك ايضا
المنزل دمر بشكل كبير الان اا هنا
المواطنين يعني يتحدثون عن همم الاماكن
التي يمكن ان يلجا اليها او الاقارب الذين
لا يمكن ان يلجاوا اليهم خاصه ان درجات
الحراره منخفضه جدا والوضع همم طبعا صعب
جدا وانقطاع الكهرباء المستمر الوضع في
العاصمه 40% من المدينه همم هي خارج تغطيه
شبكه الكهرباء تم اطلاق اربعه 64 صاروخا
همم نحو الاراضي الاخرانيه المختلفه في
اودس بروجه هكذا في سومي وميكا لايف وحتى
الغربه الاوكراني في الفيف وكذلك في مدينه
اه شريجه اعلن طبعا اعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانيه عن الدعم هؤلاء المواطنين او
البحث او او توفير سكن بديل له بايضا حتى
تتم صيانه هذه المنازل او استعاده منازل
لهم نعم
ما هي التداعيات ربما لهذه العمليات
العسكريه سواء في كيف او في
المناطق ربما المواجهات العسكريه على
الاوضاع في موسكو يعني ان كان هناك من
تداعيات في المواقف العسكريه والسياسيه
مرحبا خالد حقيقه اليوم كما تحدثت الدفاع
في بيانها كان هناك طبعا تكثيف نشط في
اربعه اتجاهات للقصف في جميع النواحي
اوكرانيا من بينها طبعا جنوب دونات
كمتحدثت الدفاع اليوم كان هناك تحديد نحو
30 مقاتل اوكراني همم في منطقه حركيه ايضا
تم القضاء على منظومه دفاع اوكرانيه
بالاضافه الى تدمير منظومه ايضا تابعه
للقوات الوكرانيات اذا هو كمان معتز همم
كل يوم من الدفاع همم هو الحديث يوم حديث
نفسه يجري عن العمليه العسكريه التي تجيها
روسيا في اوكرانيا لم يكن هناك اليوم
حقيقه همم اي همم زياده في تصريحات على
خلفيه القصف الذي شهدته اوكرانيا منذ صباح
اليوم لم يكن هناك تحديث او تبرير لهذا
الفصل المكثف الذي همم
توجه الى اوكرانيا منذ صباح اليوم الحديث
اليوم كان قبل المعتاد وكان هناك ايضا
حديث عن همم عن همم تدمير مجموعه ايضا من
المقاتلين الاوكرانيين في جنوب دونيس كما
قالت اديفا عليهم في بيانها
هل من دلالات كانت يا اخيرا على ايه
توجهات جديده ربما في همم
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه الان في التعامل مع
معطيات الحرب سريعا
حقيقه خالد كمال
الرئيس الروسي مع القاده العسكريين واليوم
كنا شهدنا الضم اربع سفن حربيه جديده الى
الاسطول البحري الروسي وكان قد توعد
الرئيس الروسي بانه سيزيد وزير العمل
وبناء السفن الحربيه كان اليوم على راسها
اطلاق الغواصه الحربيه
من مواصفاتها ان قادر على حمل 16
صاروخا باريسيا عابرا للقارات الى روسيا
طبعا تزيد من تكثيف عمليه قواتها او عمليه
بناء السفن او حتى همم تصنيع الاسلحه على
خلفيه طبعا الخبره التي سبتها كما تحدث
الرئيس الروسي من العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا